our identity and our sense of nationhood
to an extent is connected to the
language that we speak
sometimes it becomes a political
statement more and more that's become
the case for people who identify as
mongolian
most of them live in the country
mongolia or
in china's province of inner mongolia
language emerged there as a lightning
rod issue last year after beijing
announced mandarin
would replace mongolian in core school
subjects
many parents there saw it as an effort
by china to erase their culture
correspondent matthias bolinger went to
the city of hohat
after rare protests erupted over the new
policy here's a look back
at the tense atmosphere he observed
there i am now
approaching one of these schools as you
can see security measures are high
police is stationed in front of this
school
and the atmosphere is tense the
beginning of the week
students tried to organize a strike they
wouldn't attend
classes because of the new bilingual
courses
but police has exerted pressure on the
families
and now it seems most students are back
in school again
as you can see here as well lots of
security
there are a few people outside maybe
some parents as well waiting
but mostly we see these men were
standing here
and they seemed to be afraid that
further
demonstrations could happen
and i am told that i'm not allowed to
film here this is not really a surprise
by one of the guards so
i'm moving on a little bit
those efforts by beijing to diminish the
mongolian language within china has
caused a stir across the border in
mongolia proper
a country of three million people there
the language's classic script
is now seeing a revival
it used to be an artifact of history now
it's a sign of protest
not for what it says but because of the
way it's written
in vertical hodom script most mongolians
grew up using cyrillic
but this ancient script is making a
comeback sparked by what's happening in
inner mongolia
across the border in china
protests to save the mongolian language
in inner mongolia went
viral here
i believe mongolians were not aware that
inner mongolians were so
dedicated to their ethnic culture and
the language
until people saw their protests
the sudden revival started earlier this
year after beijing introduced a language
reform in
inner mongolia schools had to replace
mongolian with mandarin as the language
of instruction for core classes
critics say the policy aims to
assimilate local minorities into the
dominant han culture
and led to rare protests in the region
it also hit a nerve in neighboring
mongolia
it should be alarming to us to know that
people who speak our language
are losing that identity
the inner mongolians fight isn't just a
fight to use the native language
this is a fight to remain mongolian
but that inspiration takes quite a bit
of concentration
students have to master archaic language
and learn new grammar rules
hudum is also in need of a digital
facelift
developers have also been at work
designing ways to incorporate the
vertical script into apps
to read and write in proficiency we need
social media platforms to practice and
use the mongolian script
our way of communication has already
shifted
the script should exist in digital
platforms
that's how we can save our script and
identity
still all mongolians really need to
learn who them is a paper and pen
then practice makes perfect
for more we have journalist halloween
bayatsuk joining us from ulaanbaatar
mongolia can you tell us more about how
mongolians in mongolia
react to china's new language policy
first of all thank you for the
opportunity yes the
mongolians are pretty much reacted
the the protest video of inner
mongolians singing the famous song
uh called stay as mongolian when they're
protesting broke hearts of many modern
mongolians
who are too busy to study english or
foreign other foreign languages as
priority
but had no intention to
uh to think of their tradition or threat
or their culture and or their national
identity
in the mongolian protests yes in short
the protest made mongolians in mongolia
to make more effort to study their uh
to study their own uh vertical script
um the protests made us realize that the
this script and the language is the
essential part
of our national and identity so they
so we thought that it must be carried on
so it carried on
generation to generation yeah um
[Music]
also i'd like to uh mention that protest
those protests and protest videos not
only uh inspired us studied the language
it also
spiked discussions about the
relationship between
two mongolians the mongolians in
mongolia and the mongolians
in inner mongolia yeah so give us a
sense of the level of cross-border
exchange between mongolians
and inner mongolians is there much
communication between the two groups or
not really
ah in order to answer that question
i have to give provide you some facts
for example mongolia
was sealed off from the world 70 years
during the
soviet union so the communication
connection was lost so we were we were
only
able to talk each other or interact each
other
after the after mongolia became
democratic
and also there are some problems of
teaching uh
teaching history the way they teaching
history is
pretty much uh not enough so
mongolians in mongolia have
misunderstanding about inner mongolians
we used to think that inner mongolians
are
chinese or half chinese or they already
become
chinese people that's uh
that's what what that's what we used to
think
but not now it's changed thanks to all
those protests
we learned that we learned that the
inner mongolians are just like
us um they are so loyal to their
national
uh culture um national language
and they are ready to sacrifice their
life
to protect their own culture
language script
thank you so much for your time
you